talking of unlikely encounters because
this was all in the papers because your
your little well just because what we
read in our papers I got yeah I got a
car so this was the was it you think
rugged right
it was Jenny was James drunk is James
Blunt China get his pop career back the
papers I don't know there wasn't a lot
of people there that night so you can
say allegedly what happened okay
allegedly one of the princesses
Eugenia Beatrice one of them and James
Blunt and Ed Sheeran we're in a room was
a million a palace and James blood
allegedly wanted to be knighted is that
a euphemism and so one of the princesses
found a handy sword what item did you
not read this in the papers I didn't
know James Blunt was involved up to that
point anyway there was a bit of
swordplay and Ed sure and got caught the
face is that right no I I have no idea
how that story came out I have no idea
cuz blight it was so tight it was and
like for like two weeks afterwards I had
this huge gash on my face and people
would be like Oh what happened you'd be
like ah I fell
[Laughter]
I've read will that you have this
amazing amount of music that you haven't
released but tracks with extraordinary
artists like Michael Jackson and prints
and people like that
will you ever release those tracks no
because you know especially artists like
Michael Jackson we're working with
Michael Jackson is his critique and his
two cents so you know without him
guiding on completing it it's not my
right to to do that he was a friend so I
wouldn't I want to do that and what was
the story that you brought Michael
Jackson Prince - yes you brought Michael
Jackson and Prince together yeah for one
time we had a show in in Vegas and
Michael Jackson called hey what's
Michael okay yeah so I heard you guys
are doing a show tonight yeah we go on
at nine o'clock rats I got to put the
kids to sleep so I was like well we I'm
performing with Prince later on at 12:00
so anyways Michael came to see me rock
with Prince and it was at a met it was a
magnificent night to see it was me Chris
Tucker and in watching me Chris Tucker
Michael Jackson watching Prince rockland
sage so to make a long story short print
steps off the stage and plays the bass
in Michael Jackson's face it rips the
freaking face and ten different pieces
did a little loop make a longer story
shorter Mike Jackson leaves and goes
home and says leave me a house of
breakfast so I go to his house with
breakfast knock on the door first words
he says when I was Prince playing the
bass in my face
lights out like a power
[Applause]
[Music]
I can feel the mist every time we kiss
just didn't know it down for like this
there's a there's a flash-forward
warning will it will rain in the morning
and there'll be puddles in the bed I
want to do
[Applause]
the worthless there'll be puddles in the
bed the weatherman say yep
why were the puddles in the bed
[Applause]
listen girl Vogler's girl the weatherman
said it's cloudy skies right there
between your thighs
I want it soaking wet all over the beds
do you sing lyrics he broke them
so now you would think you would think
that people would just see this
beautiful garment on the on the World
Wide Web and you just admire it kind of
doesn't really look lovely
but of course they can't they they do
compare it as you said to this they also
they also turned it into a perhaps most
delicious of all against his beef slice
did my fresh prince rad eight million
YouTube hits was on that I can see your
face you like what has he latched well
this time I brought my DJ Jazzy Jeff
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here we go here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is sweet right so the fans because
the fans who go to do it
they then of course want to blog about
it because they've had this amazing
experience when they vlog about it's
borderline confusing on it whether they
had a good time or not so here are some
of the blog things so we were asked to
go to the living room sit down not to
how much I was sweating during that
moment I was like the [ __ ] is gonna
happen keep up then all of a sudden she
just pops up out of nowhere she appeared
out of thin air like David Copperfield
so she sexually playing her album for us
let me tell you the noise think about of
my mouth who was not human legit almost
old mama swift to call me an ambulance
cuz I was going to make
[Applause]
so much because they always talk about
dying
rest in peace me r.i.p me died dead we
did a little break as she was bossing
around rice krispie treats and cookies
and I've spoken to her mom for a little
and then I walked back in and she was
like hey babe thanks for coming do you
want to treat why was that guy would
what I think
[Applause]
this is brilliant mid sense that you
stopped talking' appointed to Amanda it
said Amanda I'm so glad to hear Amanda
died
[Applause]
perfectly finally guys just wait for the
one she did with Imogen Heap
cuz damn that one slayed everyone to
heaven her back while listening to the
song I literally had to plan
[Applause]
[Music]